let's go next to our caller from the
3:03 area code who's calling today from
303 this is Richard
hey Richard what's up well I wanted to
ask you tend to be a B become
progressive I moved to Colorado about
five years ago and I think I have the
political will to no go to any Senate
and or congressional committee and just
you know make a pitch but my question to
you that goes farther that builds on
what might what I just said is that are
you willing to go to the barn in
campaign and asked that very question I
have no idea what you're talking about
your so let me see if I understand
you're willing to go to the Colorado
politicians and ask them for things you
want that was the first thing you said
right correct okay here saying and I
will EMI David Pakman willing to go to
the Biden campaign and ask them for
something I mean I'm gonna be honest I'm
not a journalist so I don't have the
schedule of where the Bartlet campaign
will be from day in day now I'm not that
in I'm not that focused on that campaign
okay I'm sure it's early I might as well
just painted off that that quest to you
if you're interested if you're not
interested I get it you have stuff to do
but after being in the Denver protests
of getting tear gas and pepper spray I
wasn't really a big fan of that so I did
some deep dive thinking and I came to
the realization that maybe maybe just
maybe two DEA become progressive what
would it look like who would it who
would run it or there are any agencies
that will compound onto the DEA for
scientific exploration what what could
the DEA become what rather than just
being an enforcement arm of the Justice
Department and Richard is this now is
this a different topic now than will I
go to a Biden event and ask him a
question I'm sorry I'm just trying to
keep up well I'm trying to figure that
answer
I'll let you decide if it's two
different issues but if you've got or if
you're in the press box you get the
opportunity to ask that question maybe
maybe it's the same question I don't
want maybe it's the same pumping
alright well Richards let me look into
that okay all right thank you all right
man
Richard we've taken detailed copious
notes and we will we will investigate